hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today will take a
gigantic bear and a man bird and make
them duke it out for your amusement okay
well kinda see we don't have the means
to get a real bear into this studio and
I'm pretty sure Weigel would have a
conniption if I suddenly went all Ace
Ventura and started inviting exotic wild
animals onto the set but now the good
news there's a movie called Birdman and
it's really good and there's a movie by
that same director called the Revenant
which does feature a big ass bear so why
not just have 2015's the Revenant take
on its big bro 2014's Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance that is
the full title of the film I gave it to
you here that fulfills my contract
heretofore I'll just be calling it
Birdman or Birdman uvi it's too much
it's a little bit too much I can tell
they're both astonishing works of art
that excel at transporting us to
locations as varied as New York's modern
Theater District or the Great Canadian
wilderness in the early part of the
1800s and their connective tissue is the
genius behind the camera Alejandro
Gonzalez inaritsu who somehow pulled off
directing both films and releasing them
in back-to-back years which is the
sports equivalent of coaching two
different teams to consecutive Super
Bowl championships actually it's like
you won the Super Bowl one year then the
World Series the next thank you these
two films couldn't be further apart on
the surface but today we'll take a deep
look and investigate what similarities
they may have and ultimately one movie
will emerge as the champion adding
another coveted win to an already
impressive award season Hall in one
corner we have Birdman the story of a
former superhero caliber actor hoping to
reinvigorate his career with a Broadway
comeback in the other corner it's the
Revenant a harrowing flick that centers
on one man hell-bent on icy cold Revenge
way back in 1823. I really don't want to
get on the Run alongside of either set
of characters so this is set to be a
versus all-timer and it's up to me Mark
Ellis to make the final call to quote
Scar from The Lion King oh goody you are
such a naughty boy here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score round three characters round four
iconic moments and then we'll do a Wild
Card round it could include anything
from cinematography to set design to
hurdles overcome during the shoot both
Productions have stories to tell fun
fact recently on versus we did a
celebration of Alejandro Gonzalez
inoritsu and Alfonso Quran we celebrate
folks on this show by making them
compete against each other it was the
director of Children of Men and gravity
against the Birdman and Revenant guy who
won I can't tell you you gotta watch the
episode I'm a vault of Secrets a steel
trap of information and I never give
away classified level five Clan I can't
remember I'll be perfectly honest you
don't don't put me on the spot man but
it's all for fun and games and we all
take a journey back to when we call
these the 20 teens ah we were so young
all right Bird folk ready Wilderness
Travelers bundled up this is gonna be
fun Let's Get It On
round one box office
before we spill the beans and reveal how
many pintos were counted for each Flix
theatrical run can we just take a moment
to appreciate that these two movies both
turned huge profits despite the fact
that they weren't superhero Blockbusters
or summertime comedic romps or spooky
season [ __ ] reboots just good old
well-made original Cinema although
Birdman can technically be labeled a
superhero movie or an extremely dark
comedy and the Revenant was based on a
novel and Hugh glass the lead character
was an actual person look they're both
great movies and people showed up to
witness them in droves so let's start
with you Mr glass no no no no no no no
no no no not you Samuel L you just rest
and try not to make any trains go crazy
Hugh glass and the Revenant is played by
Growing Pains Alum Leonardo DiCaprio who
happens to nowadays be a pretty gigantic
star in Hollywood anytime he shows up in
a project you know he's giving his all
and the good folks of Earth showed up to
Bear a witness you get it I said um I
said bear the Revenant is not Leo's
highest grossing film ever but that's
mainly because he was in that boat movie
whose Name Escapes me but I think he got
called at the end of that one too was
there room on the raft it's a debate for
another day
Titanic would haul in over 2 billion
dollar D7 and any movie not named Avatar
or The Avengers ain't getting close to
that but it also proves his star power
even at that tender young age the
Revenant is currently his third highest
grosser ever at 532 million dollars
across the globe it only Trails Titanic
and Inception hey that Inception movie
that had a pretty good cast right
including Tom Hardy who is the
antagonist in the Revenant and there is
a method to my madness he's good at what
he does right oh he's the best just for
funsies Leonardo D has five more movies
that have all taken in at least 300
million in global bullion can you name
them ah yes in descending order Django
Unchained The Wolf of Wall Street Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood Catch Me If You
Can and The Great Gatsby if you're
yelling Shutter Island at your streaming
device you got oh so close you don't
know me
299 million for that one okay so we got
a 500 million burger for the Revenant is
there any way Birdman can compete kinda
and Michael Keaton the star of said
avian boy picture remains competitive
with DiCaprio thanks in large part due
to his superhero prowess and his
animated work Batman and Batman Returns
team up for almost 700 million dollars
and Toy Story 3 and minions have each
taken in over a billion bucks plus that
Spider-Man fella tends to put butts in
seats and homecoming gross almost 900
million dollars hot dog but Birdman
couldn't quite fly that high it landed
at a cool 102 million dollars globally
which doesn't sound like it has any
chance of matching wits with the
Revenant but let's take a look at
profitability shall we Birdman's budget
is estimated to be around 20 million
dollars that's a lot to you and me as a
matter of fact I'd be happy to split
that with you I'll even put the tax bill
but to Tinseltown that's a drop in the
bucket and now we know it was a wise
bucket drop because the film made five
times that in theaters the Revenant cost
a little more to Lumber onto the big
screen to the tune of 135 million bones
and that's without any fancy lighting
equipment I'd put money on the fact that
the lights in this Studio are probably
more than inaritu used for his movie
meaning I'm better with than Leonardo
DiCaprio like him I also drive a Ford
Fusion it's a lease okay so one movie
was super expensive to make and the
other a relative shoestring budget and
both turned out super positive margins a
waiting studio boardrooms and for more
Giggles these two films represent the
top three of Alejandro's filmography in
terms of money made the meat in that
sandwich in between the Revenant and
Birdman is Babel which took in 132
million dollars back in 2006. so when we
factor in all these elements the sheer
number that is half a billion it's just
too much to ignore again this film is
Leonardo DiCaprio's third highest
grosser and if Michael Keaton was in
this movie it would have been his fourth
highest Money Maker ever the greater
accomplishment may have been turning 20
million dollars into what we see with
Birdman but this round is about what you
did at the theaters and I chomped the
most popcorn to the Revenant the dudes
on screen eating raw Weber and I'm
poorly unhappy buttering up my corn to
each their own and to the Revenant goes
the first Battle of the day Alejandro
Gonzalez inoritu goes up one to nothing
over himself 2015-1 2014 zip you are
lame round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score now we start getting into
the good stuff investing in a project
and reaping boffo box office as a result
is wonderful but when you're a director
the caliber of an inaritsu you're
looking to create Cinema on the highest
level as in critically lauded audience
adored award-winning movies both of the
voice in contention today I feel bad
calling them flicks the theater
sweetheart don't be so self-conscious
the motion pictures in this contest were
both pegged as Prime Oscar contenders
before they were even released and with
good reason inoritsu had already built
up an impressive track record thanks to
Prior features like amoris peros and
Babel which took on the canned film
festival's top prize for a director so
we knew we'd be in for good stuff but
how do those critics and audiences feel
walking out of the theaters let's eat
our veggies first and head over to the
Tomato Meter
Birdman's sword in 2014 on the strength
of a nest chock full of positive reviews
91 is where it gracefully landed in the
Tomato patch with a critics consensus
that says a thrilling lead forward for
director Alejandro Gonzalez inoritu
Birdman is an ambitious technical
showcase powered by a layered story and
outstanding performances from Michael
Keaton and Edward Norton for more fun
performer career comparing let's look at
another Birdman star's filmography and
see how it shakes out Emma Stone step
right up dude seriously that 91 is good
for her second best Tomato Meter report
card ever trailing only the favorite and
its 93 numeral Birdman is tied for the
stone silver medal with La La Land and
tops zombieland's very deserve at 89 if
you're still keeping score at home
Birdman's 91 is good for third place on
Edward Norton's career movie resume
which is topped by moonrise kingdoms 93
and apparently that Michael Keaton guy
can really make an impression I'm Batman
his best effort here is Toy Story 3 is
98 followed by spotlights 97 okay so
Spotlight is the 2015 film that beat out
the Revenant for best picture while
inaritsu defeated spotlight's Tom
McCarthy in the best director category
the connecting of dots between these
movies is infinite and now we look at
the revenue it was highly anticipated
given the star power on and behind the
camera and when it hit it landed fresh
with a 78 that's good that's very good
it just ain't Birdman so B dog is set to
win his first point of the afternoon
unless the Revenant can astonish us with
its verified audience score but before
we get there allow me to build some
suspense by comparing the Revenant 78
percent with star Tom Hardy's
distinguished geography yeah Tommy's
been doing work y'all dude's got three
movies in the 90s including lot Dunkirk
and Mad Max Fury Road they're all great
movies did you see Locke it's just him
on the phone in a car for 90 minutes and
it's riveting I could watch that dude
text in an airport for an hour and a
half the Revenant barely crawls into
Hardy's top 10 winning at the number
nine spot and it's number 11 on
DiCaprio's Tomato Meter history which is
topped by Catch Me If You cans 96 okay
so Birdman is impressing Ozzy Osbourne
by flying high again but will the
Revenant Bark at the Moon with the
audience quite simply yes it improves on
its critical number by jumping to 84
percent how about that bird fella it
tumbles down to an Earthbound 78 with
you the good moviegoers avert I would
hesitate to say either one is really a
crowd pleaser but there both such
stunning filmmaking achievements that
we're gonna do make these rotten this is
this is the kind of review that turns
people into Living Legends for Alejandro
Gonzalez interrito himself Birdman ranks
as his second best effort in terms of
Tomato Meter amoris peros which
translates to loves a [ __ ] that sounds
much more romantic in Spanish doesn't it
it's tops at 93 so looking at all these
ooey gooey stats both films impress me
with their critical and audience derived
percentages but Birdman cracking the 90s
is more of an accomplishment for me than
the Revenant sneaking up the charts with
its audience score the unexpected virtue
of ignorance a concept of which your
host is very familiar gets the round two
win and we got us a tied ball game one
to one
round three characters and now we arrive
at the most interesting round of today's
episode of versus so far because this
one will highlight the people that star
co-star show up Cameo all the people in
the movie and how compelling of a
characterization they provided in short
did we care about y'all absolutely this
is particularly fascinating for the
Birdman movie and the Revenant two films
that were heavy on a-listers but the
style of filmmaking from inaritsu might
have cast a shadow over those
performances so get the black light
we're watching into this round like when
a news Outlet investigates a hotel room
to see how dirty they really are you
ever see that if you're a frequent
traveler like me don't just make sure
next time you go into a hotel room
you're wearing gloves before handling
the TV remote is it true the Revenant
had a Tinseltown Titan matchup between
Leo and Tom Hardy V DiCaprio in the
1800s who would Triumph who could
conquer the elements who might win an
award for Leo's portrayal of Hugh glass
the prep is as compelling as the
performance this dude basically did a
whole season's worth of Fear Factor
challenges to get into the vibe a Hugh
glass s a guide for Trappers making
their way through the Dakotas after an
attack by the arikara tribe whose Chief
was seeking his own kidnapped daughter
glass is all but left for dead by Tom
Hardy's John Fitzgerald but not before
John kills Hawk the half Pawnee son of
glass in front of the helpless father
glass undergoes a visceral and brutal
healing process then dumps himself into
white water rivers to escape more
attacks and Propel himself towards
Revenge DiCaprio went to Great Lengths
in hopes of authenticating this role
with reports that he even ate raw animal
liver to simulate the diet of the time
and I believe that still Falls within
the Atkins protocols playing glass on
any given day would require intense
action sequences or intimate combat
scenarios or just walking up a hill in
freezing temperatures like all our
parents had to do going to school none
of it sounds fun but it ends up packing
a wallop and giving us a remarkable
confrontation between two actors at the
top of their game Arc Mosley if you like
take away this up from real quick and
easy whenever it has to know that you
give up I do that and while don't all
Gleason Will Poulter and Forest good
luck help round out the impressive cast
Birdman is the more established Ensemble
piece led by Michael Keaton as Reagan
Thompson in a role that he may not have
been born to play but was inadvertently
trained for in the decades prior you see
Thompson is a former Big Shot actor who
played the iconic Birdman on the big
screen from 1989 to 1982. that's not
like anyone you know hi
Bruce Wayne Keaton himself was Batman in
two films the first in 89 and the return
in 92 but separating reality from
fiction Thompson has a nagging inner
monologue as Birdman smells like balls
even as the actor himself tries to
revive his Fame by pulling off a
Broadway production of the play what we
talk about when we talk about love
according to Keaton you would have to go
from funny to disturbing to deeply sad
back to Darkly funny all then the span
of one scene the entire movie plays out
like one long continuous shot so there
is very little margin of error for the
performers who also list Emma Stone Zach
Galifianakis and Edward Norton among
their ranks stone is a recovering addict
and Reagan's daughter whom he hopes to
reconnect with enlisting her as his
assistant Norton steps in to replace
another thespian injured when a lighting
rig fell on them and he happens to be
dating Naomi Watts as Leslie also
starring in the production Andrea
risborough and Galifianakis respectively
shine as Reagan's girlfriend of the
lawyer and the always great Amy Ryan is
again note perfect as Reagan's ex-wife
Sylvia maybe a little more name
recognition for Birdman over the
Revenant but you will not find a bad
performance in either movie you'd also
be hard-pressed to find actors who
weren't pushed to the very limits of
their craft by inhabiting these roles
the Revenant often featured brutal
conditions that made getting even a
simple take extremely arduous and
inaritsu's insistence at using almost
all natural lighting meant that every
action call had to count or else the day
would be lost I dare say that the budget
for that historical epic wasn't
originally proposed to be over a hundred
million dollars but delays and crew
members leaving the project and
Alternate shooting sites a continent
Away really add up but the final product
gave us a host of Unforgettable
performances however in this case
Birdman arriving a year before helps its
cause sure the Stars may have been more
comfy in the shooting conditions
probably involved more mercury in the
thermometer so the difficulty was
instead nailing the long takes on a
limited schedule and I do mean long
takes shut up shut up to Keaton's
previous quote you would have actors
doing up to 10 minutes at a time and any
little hiccup would ruin the take if
level line a boom mic drops that craft
Services Beefaroni kicks in at the wrong
time you gotta go back to scratch it's
kind of like being on one of those
baking shows that everyone loves
watching if the cake doesn't come out
immaculate it gets tossed in your face
and you gotta start all over both Keaton
and DiCaprio were nominated for their
lead performances at the Oscars with Leo
winning his year Tom Hardy and Edward
Norton were also up for the supporting
category and Emma Stone earned a
supporting knot as well but from top to
bottom the cast and Birdman had the
bigger challenge because of how
codependent they had to be on each other
to get a scene in the can I'd much
rather have existed with the pressure on
that set than survive the elements and
intense battle sequences in the Revenant
but for all the memorable worlds that we
do get in Birdman I'm giving that the
win in round three which more than makes
up for those runner-up ribbons of the
Academy Awards right here we uh can we
just mail the cast of prize like a
trophy do we have trophies people have
heard of this show we're is getting
around and Birdman is now up two to one
round four iconic moments so those
performances were great right two
top-notch casts coming together to make
something cool but if we're going to see
a movie about a guy whose Alter Ego is
Birdman we're gonna expect some pretty
memorable sequences right yeah and if
I'm paying to see a film that's about
revenge in the freezing Wilderness I
want to feel like I'm there except the
freezing and the Wilderness part I want
to get invested and that's what this
round is about which film Birdman or the
Revenant provided us with the most
Thrills chills and Spills should we
allow chills it feels like the Revenant
is going to have the upper hand there
but to be fair to bird guy there's a ton
of action in here and well that's kind
of the point of the movie if you forgive
me for sounding like the back of a VHS
jacket Birdman has one long kinetic tour
de force that never lets up that's the
Gap it's all one scene even as we Veer
from locations like a theater rehearsal
to the streets of New York to a hospital
room and Beyond hospitals would have
been really handy in 1823 no such luck
for Hugh glass but somehow he was able
to stack his Opus with iconic scenes as
well let's start off with them moment
that's going to make all of our Chicago
Pals very happy duh Bears
although Hugh wouldn't be quite so jolly
about this particular grizzly bear one
who is much more ferocious than this
year's version in the NFL glass gets
mauled by a gigantic Sid Luckman and is
Left for Dead by other Trappers not only
does the rare usage of industrial Light
and Magic's Wizardry in this movie make
for a harrowing Showdown it also sets up
our chain of events that will follow Tom
Hardy as most of us would assumes it's
only a matter of time before leosa comes
to either his wounds or the elements or
another human or animal fracas fun fact
so you guys remember that really old
movie The Empire Strikes Back
whether on the snow planet with The
Walking Dead Hugh glass recreates that
later in the film as he's looking for
any warmth in a storm and according to
Legend DiCaprio actually got snuggled
inside a real animal carcass in the film
it's a horse but speculation has been
that the actual stand-in deceased
creature could have been a horse or a
bear or even a Tonton I thought they
smell bad
on the outside I technically don't know
what came first Empire was released in
1980 meaning it's not that old Peter
Parker but the Revenant takes place in
the early 1800s so that happened before
or after the rebels went to Hoth a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away either
way the Revenant is the closest thing
that gen Z has to the hit 90 show When
Animals Attack but man vs nature is just
part of this journey the arikara attack
is brutal and does not hold back it's
amazingly well shot given the chaos of
what's happening inarito and his team do
a marvelous job of placing Us in the
center of the camp and we're just
closing our eyes hoping we make it out
alive okay so maybe Birdman never
reaches that level of violence but the
inner turmoil felt by Reagan Thompson is
very real Birdman might be real too
Keaton's thrown around New York whether
fully clothed or down to his skivvies is
always compelling and when the bird boys
kicks in the emotion ratchets up Birdman
the Phoenix Rises Reagan is clearly
haunted by this thing but it's so
confident in its intonation when
convincing Thompson that he is Birdman
and that the laws of gravity don't apply
to him similarly a walk around the block
with Edward Norton can quickly escalate
to an argumentative confrontation and
the two a-listers going tets packs an
emotional Wallop it's also really fun to
watch Reagan deal with the press and
critics in a bar he has it out with a
prominent theater reviewer and then the
Foreign Press comes into his dressing
room both instances as well as Poppins
from his lawyer ex and daughter are
wonderful examples of the energy this
flick moves with it's a motion picture
in the most literal sense of the term
constant moving goings on and it's
always building momentum towards an epic
Climax and a curious denuma we know
where the revenant's heading and it's a
final confrontation and a bid for
revenge on the part of glass and just
like the rest of the film it sprawls out
in such a way that we feel like we're
part of the action Birdman closes with
an Exquisite and violent Curtain Call
then daughter Emma Stone simply looks
out a window and smiles giving us a hint
as to what the hell is going on out
there and while Birdman is seemingly one
continuous shot the Revenant gets bonus
points for staging such stunning
sequences in real environments with
limited lighting but phenomenal talents
in front of and behind the lens if we're
just looking at the most iconic scenes
that made a film truly Unforgettable the
Revenant sneaks past Birdman in my book
but I can barely read so take it with a
grain of salt I'm good at math though
and now we're all tied up two to two
[Music]
what the hell did you do that for I like
that poster and now it's time for the
Wild Card round Legacy oh it all comes
down to this the enduring emotions that
we associate with two of the most
singularly unique movies of the 2010s
they're waiting for something huge we'll
give it to them but before we break down
anything else associated with these two
films it's past time to celebrate one of
the Geniuses behind them both
cinematographer Emmanuel uzbeki he's one
of a kind yet twice in a row he pulled
off a breathtaking final piece of art
and took home the top prize of the
Academy Awards in back-to-back years for
Birdman and the Revenant that's ability
right there it's got to be enough on a
resume to be able to mimic a continuous
shot or frame up scenes in the freezing
cold elements with only a few hours of
natural light each day lose Becky pulls
off both feets like he's been doing this
since birth oh and he also won the same
highest honor Oscar has for
cinematographers the year before Birdman
for Alfonso quran's gravity three times
in a row that's even better than Tom
Hanks in the 90s hey and while we're on
the topic of awards both films were much
more universally wanted than Reagan
Thompson felt when he had to deal with
critics Birdman was nominated by the
academy for nine Awards taking home four
including best picture best director and
best original screenplay to go along
with the best cinematographer meanwhile
the Revenant was up for a total of 12
Awards winning three for best actor Leo
Best Director Alejandro and in what must
have started to become a nuisance in the
schedule of Emmanuel uzbeki best
cinematography it makes this call so
tough between two very different films
that somehow were Guided by the same
hand the movie was also an original
screenplay co-written by inaritu and
that might be one of the separating
factors here the story of huge glass
based on the real guy had been told
before but never in a visual medium and
no one could have envisioned the impact
it would have but Birdman and its
originality its relatability to Michael
Keaton's own career and the chances it
takes in storytelling is too much to
overcome at the end of the day Birdman
takes the point and thus wins the match
in a nail biter
foreign
got his start on Growing Pains Michael
Keaton also kicked around Mr Rogers
Neighborhood for a brief time they're
both amazing towns and they're both in
phenomenal films that we got to
celebrate today courtesy of their
director Alejandro Gonzalez inaritu
that's all just my take of course now
let me have it with yours on social
media I'm at Mark Ellis live make sure
you're following us here at Rotten
Tomatoes or head over to
rottentomatoes.com for all the latest in
the world of TV movies freezing cold
epics uh bird related pictures and
everything else in between thanks for
watching I'm Mark Ellis we'll see you
soon on versus and I am gonna go get
warm somewhere